people are crying out for prey to be
released in theaters thanks to
terrifying stunts and creature designs
but mostly that cute shelter doggo right
so much awesomeness went into making
this movie and we're covering it all
number one trees weren't part of the
equation that was all dakota beaver
leaping off the back of the horse and
throwing a spear into the predator they
did actually hire a stunt double for
that shot they wanted a stunt double so
that their lead didn't you know break a
leg of course but dakota wanted to do
the shot so bad
he eventually got his way after
pressuring the stunt coordinator he was
wired up and put on top of the horse and
well he hit a tree more than once and he
landed pretty hard but they got the
shots they needed and he found the whole
thing a lot of fun to shoot number two
imagine 2018's predator in the 1700s
they had to downgrade the predator to
make it a fair fight while already
limiting his weapons they considered
maybe he should be something more
primitive and what does that make of his
character they thought about making him
a neanderthal at one point too but that
design looks too clunky
dane's head is in the neck of the
predator
dane's also facing the ground the
mechanical head weighed more than 11
pounds too the creature wasn't totally
practical though the moving pictures
company developed a cg predator that
they used for inhuman performances to
augment or replace parts of the
practical suit and for close-ups when
they needed a more exaggerated look
number three this was no trip to the spa
the mud pit was just disgusting to film
in amber mid thunder admitted i had
heard about it beforehand somebody had
done a test and was like oh it's not
that bad it's just like water with
leaves in it so she thought easy great
amazing it'll just be like a mud bath or
whatever
wrong it was definitely not just water
with leaves so she has no idea what this
thick goo is but she feels like it's
been absorbed into her skin and then
nothing could prepare her for
the smell oh the smell the director said
it didn't smell weird until it touched
human flesh what a disgusting thing to
say right number four we're surprised
this process didn't take all day getting
the suit on was actually a pretty quick
event it took 15 minutes or less to get
dane deligro suited up at least the main
bits then they had to glue a patch on
the back to cover the zipper and slip
his gloves on and of course put on that
giant head they were nice enough to
leave the head off of him as much as
possible it's probably one of the
roughest sets that i've seen any of our
practical effects creatures working on
it's actually a very thin suit in a lot
of places less than a quarter inch thick
but no that 12-pack does not belong to
the actor i am not as ripped as he is
number five usually you have the name of
your movie by the time you're printing
the script
that was just
not important for this movie we guess
because they didn't have a name for the
thing even while they were mid-shoot
ridiculous
number six it's like a dance but there's
more rolling around on the ground the
trapper fight was truly a one-shot
sequence so it required a bunch of
cowboy switches it's when an actor
switches place with their stunt double
mid scene and vice versa and in the
trapper fight shot they rolled in and
out of the scene more than a few times
how do they manage to keep their hair
and costumes looking so good
number seven working with smoke is a bad
idea never work with smoke in a field
because it was so difficult the burnt
glade scene that looked smoky and dark
was shot during bright sunny daylight
and they had five smoke machines relying
on the natural direction of the wind to
blow the smoke was a menace they'd be
standing waiting ready to go in position
the predator actor would just be getting
his head on and they would have to hold
for smoke
number eight and now for the meryl
streep of dogs coco had humble
beginnings she started off as a shelter
dog and made it to the big time with no
training amber referred to her as
a little bit of a hot mess but in a
sweet way coco wasn't intended to have
star billing they truly didn't mean for
her to be in as much of the movie as
they had her but her presence was just
so fun that she kept being asked back
number nine unlike the doggo the horse
was a natural dakota beavers may look
like a natural rider in the film but
trust us he only learned for filming
during that four week boot camp he was
riding at every possible minute and it
didn't stop there on his days off from
filming he was back on the horse and
riding again
number ten tall guys can do parkour too
the six foot nine actor who played the
predator lost 25 pounds to play the role
he also had an aggressive workout
routine he said that they wanted a lean
dynamic more animal predator
traditionally he's more of a muscular
guy he trained in parkour for two months
saying i'm six foot nine not many six
foot nine guys do parkour he also
trained in martial arts for two months
specifically his neck he teamed up with
a company called iron neck and
strengthened it for two months because
of the heavy predator head it was about
13 pounds or something which weighed
well over 10 pounds on top of all the
acting he did all the stunts and the
motion capture too number 11. why did
school take 14 years if you can learn so
many skills in a month four weeks in
calgary were dedicated to preparing
actors for their roles they did stunt
choreography and weapon training we did
the archery and spears and knives and
the tomahawk amber learned every single
sequence in its entirety because she
wanted to do everything herself saying
so i got to jump off the tree i got to
get thrown off the predator i got to
fight him despite the training amber
admitted there's nothing that really
prepares you for a week in a mud pit you
know number 12 wear a life jacket
whenever possible it may save your life
one location that really made amber
uncomfortable was the river for good
reason she said i grew up around water
but i also grew up knowing how dangerous
it is but it's okay she managed
admitting i had anxiety building on top
of anxiety on top of anxiety but once i
got in it was so fun while she did get
used to the river for the most part
there was one bit that no one could get
used to and that was the temperature
because even though it was summertime it
was glacial runoff water amber said we
were there for like five days so for
five days i would wake up and be like
ice bath number 13 not every great idea
makes it the director is a bit
disappointed that one scene he really
wanted never came to fruition a treetop
chase he said i was for whatever reason
really obsessed with having the fights
be more vertical and seeing the predator
leaping through the trees too bad that
sounds like fun maybe they'll get there
in a sequel or another prequel
number 14. coco isn't the only one who
had her film debut prey was dakota
beaver's first movie he'd auditioned for
something that fell through but his name
was still on file when he got an email
he was under the impression that this
was for a small part he sent in a self
tape then a zoom audition then another
one then he was flown out to la for a
screen test with amber only then did he
realize it wasn't just a small part all
of this flying was pretty wild for him
because he'd never really been out of
the country too much before and never by
plane so flying during covent for
filming was eerily exciting because the
airport felt like a ghost town
number 15. how do you make a prototype
predator just as scary probably the
biggest struggle anyone had was
reimagining the predator in a way that
would keep it fresh and creepy while
still honoring the original design they
really had to do something else to
better fit this story
but also the predator has a familiar
face to people now so in order to keep
the scare factor up they needed that
redesign to keep people on their toes
it's like kids being scared of santa the
first time they sit on his lap compared
to five years later okay maybe it's not
like that
you know that hollywood saying never
work with animals or children but if you
have to pick one pick a shelter dog and
if you have to pick two pick a horse as
well were you impressed by the design of
the feral predator let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things